it's good to be back at this place that
means so much to my own spiritual
development having worshiped here as a
student and having preached here on a
couple of occasions I know you you're
all liberal mainline moderate middle of
the road progressive Protestant gracious
Christians and so that means that when
you first heard Jesus story this morning
you thought you liked it
the master is throwing a great banquet
he spares nothing to honor his son so he
sends out his servants come to my
banquet sending out his invitations to
all of his friends and rich cronies and
they make excuses
he's miffed but he says hey I paid for
the caterers I've rented the hall hey go
out this time and this time I want you
to invite those who've never had an
invitation go out invite the poor and
the maimed and the people on the margins
and the people who've got nothing to do
on a Saturday night invite them and and
you like that because you like thinking
that God is gracious open handed and God
turns away from those at the center to
those at the margins and it's kind of
fun to see God turn away from his
self-righteous stiff shirt priggish
religious people and go out to the bad
go after those in the highways and the
byways who are not here this morning but
unfortunately as so often is the case
Jesus well Jesus won't leave it at that
with the gracious God
all of us think we deserve know the
thing that gets you about this story is
the completely out of line
over-the-top judgment oh those are
invited are too busy to come this is not
a good weekend well torture of them
Burnham Gilliam sent him to hell
that'll teach them to not RSVP and if
that didn't offend you
Jesus slams you again one of these poor
wretches that comes into the banquet
gets into the worst kind of trouble
because of his attire the lord of the
banquet comes in and says friend yes
you're there how did you get in here
without a tux Matthew says the guy
speechless of course he's speechless one
hour ago he was living down by the river
in a trailer he was living in a
refrigerator packing crate where's he
going to get a tux and the Lord of the
banquet says well I should be glad just
to have you here but torture him kill
him burn him send him to hell and I'll
teach him to show up here without a
cummerbund and patent leather pumps I
know that some of you have never seen
this side of Jesus Jesus begins
Matthew's Gospel with his Sermon on the
Mount blessed are the peacemakers do not
return violence when violence is done to
you and then Jesus follows that with 8
parables including this one in which God
does violence to bad people
now what we want to worship
you were invited here to say now we want
you to participate in worship as you're
called and as you're comfortable well
I'm a preacher I want to invite you to
worship as you're uncomfortable well
what we want is a God who says Oh
Saturday is bad for you I know we're all
just so busy let's make it a rain check
and then probably I'll throw another
party in January when there's absolutely
nothing to do and nowhere to go in New
Haven how about that that's what we want
no in the kingdom of God everything gets
jacked up everything gets elevated out
beyond the bounds of moderation Jim um
torture amber um cinema hell why would
this master who it first seems so
generous go completely ballistic over a
turn down of an invitation or the
inability to show up well dressed for
the occasion that's one thing I like
about you students is because many of
you have found a way to issue an
invitation to someone without their
knowing they got an invitation then when
they turn down the invitation you don't
know that you've been rejected like oh
hey I don't got anything to do this
weekend if you got nothing to do and
nowhere to go you want to go out and
then the person responds I don't care
and then you could say well I mean like
you know since there's nothing to do and
nobody to go out with and all you want
to go out okay I don't care that's great
because then you don't know you've been
turned down when you get turned down
I still remember junior year of high
school I worked on it for two months to
invite well-developed bev Beckwith to
the junior/senior and when I finally got
up the nerve to invite her
I've to the junior senior she said you
know nothing would please me more than
to go to that dance with you like I've
been living my whole 16 years just
waiting for an invitation from somebody
like you unfortunately I have a beloved
aunt that I think will die that weekend
I can't go and I still feel bad about
that but yeah this this is beyond
feeling bad I mean this is over the top
the completely inappropriate reaction of
the master of the band would still
decades ago when I was in college back
then they didn't we didn't have phones
there was only one phone in the whole
college it was down the hall in the
dormitory so if you wanted to like get
in touch with the real world you had to
go down the hall and stand in line at
that pay phone and call out but the good
thing was my room was down there near
the payphone so I could listen in there
just about every conversation and I
remember one night I'm trying to study
and I heard this guy on the phone yes
ma'am
what were ya but momma I don't know what
happened in history I got in there the
exam asked all these questions weren't
even in class and III well I mean
chemistry not chemistry I could tell
like I didn't like me the moment I
walked in that class he's had it in for
me ever since the beginning of the
semester I I
that yes ma'am oh okay I wanna do better
this semester I'm gonna do better well I
heard him slam down the phone he
staggered away he got as far as my room
he plopped down there in my room give me
a cigarette and we sit there and I said
you know parents what are you gonna do
with him you try to explain these they
just can't understand and he said and
she she can't understand because I'm the
first person in my family ever to go to
college and my mom was working two jobs
just so I can be here she called me from
the lawyer's office where she cleans up
at night so I guess she thinks she's
maybe putting more into my education and
I am right now
I can understand her being so mad you'd
like for Jesus not to Ratchet everything
up we would like for these matters to be
matters of calm and cool deliberation
after all that's what we do at the
University no matter what's on the table
we always step back and we have a
discussion and we have a frank sharing
of different points of view and then the
bell rings and then we leave
but maybe life your life consists of a
bunch of invitations and you get as old
as I am and you look back on your life
and life is a bunch of doors that were
opened and you went through and doors
that you shut and maybe they're always
consequences I know as a parent one of
the hardest things about being a parent
is
the main thing you'd like to protect
your children from is consequences
you just wish they're young uninformed
decisions didn't count as much as they
often count and when it's God's
invitation
I guess stuff gets really elevated God's
invitations for a serious matter of
course we would have accepted if we had
known how ridiculously ballistic and out
of control the master got but that's one
of the touchy things about invitations
you you don't always know that this is
something of life and deaths
significance I remember I was a student
I knew his parents he got in touch with
me more than anything else you want to
get in Duke University but he said I
fooled around a lot during high school
and I'm gonna have a tough time getting
in so against my advice he goes and
camps out literally at the admissions
office of the University and he says
he's gonna hound them until they let him
in
well they the Director of Admissions
realizing he was dealing with a
emotionally unbalanced person laid him
in and so he called me and he said guess
what I just got in Duke and I said wow I
bet you're happy
and he said well sort of I mean you know
now it's the responsibility that's
getting me I've never had this much
responsibility laid on my shoulders I
just hope I can take it
God's invitations I mean maybe see you
think you're here this morning because
you decided to be here but maybe you
were invited and from one other thing I
found you know you got to be careful
every time you pray every time you sing
a hymn every time you show up a place
like this every time you're just minding
your own business a living God just
loves to make you God's business and you
you get these invitations just mentioned
we Alabama has got the meanest
immigration law in the nation now and
right after the law was promulgated we
had a silent vigil in Birmingham and we
had prayer and I prayed Lord we didn't
know what we were doing when we elected
a dermatologist as our governor we we
were we didn't know he knew this little
about government we forgive us after the
demonstration I passed by an old
Methodist preacher standing there with
tears streaming down his eyes and I said
brother you're right to be weeping this
is a sad day for our state and he said
no these are not tears of sadness he's a
tears of joy and I said really he said
in 1964 God invited me to be part of
God's kingdom in a little town in
Alabama and I didn't have the guts to go
with God
I can't believe before I died
God's given me one more
chance I'm here well when I was a
student here in my last year I applied
to graduate school at Emory University
and they invited me down there for
interviews and I flew down to Atlanta I
checked into my hotel got to the hotel
room no sooner was I checked in there
was his banging at the door and opened
the door and there was this guy standing
there and he says hey buddy hey you're
staying on the best floor in the hotel
because tonight we're gonna have a party
to end all parties and you're invited
come on to the party and I said you know
thank you but come on the party I said
well thank you thank you so sure enough
by nine o'clock I could hear music down
the hall I could hear loud voices about
ten o'clock I heard glass breaking loud
voices ten fifteen somebody BAM down the
door and says hey hey come on come on
now you wouldn't believe it we got a
bunch of girls there from Agnes Scott
come on now and I said really I'm sorry
I have got to have some sleep please
shut the door keep the noise down well I
had a fitful night but I got up the next
morning and I opened my door and sure
enough the hallway was just strewn with
bottles and glass and walking down the
hall the door open and there was this
guy and he said man you missed a party
last night and then a voice in the room
said Joe Archie come on back and he said
I gotta go shut the door now here's my
point for your young people I'm 65 years
old I got into Emory I did very well in
my graduate work but to this day I wish
you